الان ايضا
لمتابعه الموقف
رائد قطراوي مدير الاسعاف في اريحا سيد
رائد ما تطلع منك على
على حجم الاصابات
الاصابات البشريه في عمليه الاقتحام هذه
يسعد مساكم طبعا
باقتحام مخيم عقبه جبل شريحه قبل تقريبا
الساعه
وقاموا حصلت منزل في المخيم قام توافقمنا
بالتوجه للموقع لوجود اصابات ولكن اقامه
القواتهم ومنعهم من نقل واسعاف المصابين
حيث قاموا باسعاف قرض العمل انعاش قلب
رئوي
المصابين مصاب بالصوت هاي ولكن هجموا
عليهم
واخذوا منهم المصاب ومنعوهم من نقله
وتقديم الاسعاف له وتهجموا على الموقع ولا
زالتمنا موجوده هناك في الموقع واحنا هنا
موجودين من غطي المواجهات لحد الان العدد
الاصابات يعني غير محصور لانه منعين
الاسعاف لموقع اللي هو المحاصر
انتم اين تتواجدون
احنا متواجدين حاليا في مخيم عقبه جبر
من
الاصابات ولكن الاسرائيليين يمنعونا انه
نوصل برفعوا علينا الاسلحه وبمنعولم
الوصول للاصابه يعني انتم انتم موجودون
داخل داخل المخيم لكن
عند نقطه الاصابات او نقطه الاشتباكات لا
يمكنكم الوصول
انا بحكي معك من هناك نقاط الاشتباكات
ولكن الاحتلال من الوصول الى الاصابات
والموقع اللي هو اللي فيه متواجد المحاصر
في المنزل ولحد الان ما في عنا اي معلومات
يعني دقيقه حول عدد الاصابات لانهم عمالهم
نوصل لهذه الاصابات هل ما زال اطلاق النار
مستمر
نعم
مستمر والمواجهات مستمره من الشبان
الفلسطينيين في المخيم عده محاور مخيم في
عده في عده مواقع داخل المخيم هناك
مواجهات طيب صحيح صحيح
طيب بحيث حيث تتواجد هل هل يمكنك ان تصف
لنا المشهد في المنطقه
المشهد الاحتلال موجودين في احدى المواقع
قريبين من البيت المحاصر في يوجد مواجهات
بين الشبان الفلسطينيين ومعهم يقومون
باطلاق القنابل الغاز
والرصاص المطاطي على على
الشباب اللي اعملهم بواجهوا في الاحتلال
قوات الاحتلال تتحدث بحسب اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن اعتقال ثلاثه من
الفلسطينيين هل لديك اي معلومات كيف
اعتقلوا وفي اي جهه من المخيم او اي منزل
هم حاليا محاصرين منزل في منطقه بسموها حي
السلمي
المعلومات اللي عندنا الحاليه اللي هو
اللي هو المصاب اللي كانت تم التعامل معه
منعونا من نقله اسعافه واخذوه هو الوحيد
حاليا معلومات عنه واللي هو يعني اعتقد
انه استشهد معلومات اخرى لحد الان ما فيش
مجال لانه عم يمنعونا نوصل لهذا الموقع
بحسب يعني بحسب اولا تقول انه يمكن ان
يكون استشهد يعني المعلوماتك هذه اكيده
عمالهم الشباب حكيت معهم انا بشتغلوا فيه
انعاش قال بورقاوي
فواضح بما انهم بيشتغلوا عنده تنفس ولا ما
بتفهم الاغلب يعني اليهود الاحتلال مناعهم
من انهم يستكملوا الاسعاف له
للمستشفى وعلى الاغلب انهم اخذوه واستشهد
لانه ما في سيارات اسعاف معهم الاحتلال
وطلبنا منهم
[ضحك]
رفض
ومنعونا من الاستثمار لتعافون
هذا الجريح الذي تتوقع انه قد يكون استشهد
هل يعني لا ادري ان كانت لديك معلومات هل
هو
واحد ممن كانوا مستهدفين بعمليه الاعتقال
ففي ان معلومات اخيره انه هو من احد
المستهدفين لانهم لا زالوا محاصرين المنزل
لحد الان ومنهيل وصول اي حدا للموقع طيب
اضافه الى الى ذلك هل هناك تعزيزات اضافيه
اسرائيليه
يتم استخدامها الى داخل المخيم
صحيح صحيح وصلت قوات كبيره من قوات
الاحتلال المخيم المخيم من جميع المداخل
والمخارج له
طيب ماذا عن الدروع البشريه يعني هلا قبل
قليل رئيس اللجنه الشعبيه في المخيم قال
بان القوات الاحتلال تتخذ من المواطنين
الفلسطينيين دروع بشريه هناك
في بيوتهم ومحصلينهم في المواقع الحديثه
رائد القطراوي
مدير الاسعاف في اريحا شكرا جزيلا لك